- But I spend most
of my time on the West
side, I'd get up and leave.
- It's good to get away.
- You go crazy or kill somebody.
- All right.
Trayvon. Trayvon.
Oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
Originally? South central LA.
And tell me about your family
hit both your parents growing
up. Yes.
- I was actually born with albinism.
My mother was 15 when she
had me and I was born in 69.
So I was officially raised
by my father's parents.
They took me away to
home out of the hospital
because mom was too young.
Right. In 1969.
They wouldn't give a 15 year
old educated little girl
upline, white child.
It just wasn't going to happen.
And so that's how I was
raised with my grandmother.
I didn't know.
My mother was my real mother for years.
Wow. And, but her and
my father had their own
separate housing.
They were still having
my brother and sister
but I was staying there,
legally I was never
worded to my mother, my
father and his parents.
Yeah. But I grew up in a full tribal, like
- What kind of childhood do you have?
- It was arduous.
it was lots of violence,
but I had a huge family
to protect me, but it
was a lot of violence.
A lot of fighting, a lot of teas.
And my family were very protective of me.
And it was just a lot of very
- Like towards you as well.
- I mean, now I have to do
a lot of fighting myself.
Jessica to education
- Uses mostly physical.
It sounds like it
- It was fixable.
Right? Because it's
like having an Alvin is what
people don't understand.
They'll try to destroy.
It's something that they don't understand.
And it's a lot of old wives
tales associated with it.
People that the grand mama told them this
and this about people such as
myself and it's all untrue.
what I mean?
And, but it's deeply entrenched
within the subculture, within the society.
Even in Africa, they're hunting
down people like me
and selling body parts.
And you never seen that, it's
I won't even date an
African, so I'm scared.
They're going to try and take me
to the Congo and settle on me.
- So growing up, did you, I mean
did you see your, I mean
how do you relate to the
African-American community?
You see yourself as black
or you see what I mean?
You're just, you're just
- It wasn't a big issue in my household.
Nobody ever talked about it.
I was just a family member.
I was just a baby growing up.
It wasn't an issue ever.
It wasn't even, it was outside.
You
- Know? Did you ever become
an issue in your life?
- Not for me.
And if not, for me, I'd
never had the issue.
Right. But for other
people, I mean, for me, it
it got me jobs,
- There's something wrong with you.
It's just like, you're, you're just
you just look different than everybody.
- Right.
And I don't have to dye my
hair green to be outstanding.
I see people go to great extremes
just so people can look at them.
You worked on the street.
And I tell people and I, people
especially people that I date
and, and they have to be worn.
I'm like, you've never
been a worm folder with me.
He's said, and I have to
one I'm like, when we go up
people are going to look at us
everywhere we go and peep in.
If you're not used to that, it
will make you uncomfortable.
If you never experienced that.
If you live in this world
where you just blindly go
through society and no
one even turns an eye
but if you're not used
to that and I've given
up relationships because of
that, they couldn't handle it.
It made them, they're not used to it.
they're used to being invisible.
- You're beautiful to look at.
And do you see yourself that way?
- I smart.
I'm smart.
I seen myself smart.
Beautiful to me.
I think I'm more smart than
Bernie, but I am Grace Jones
sexy. your personality
makes you a more beautiful
I'm a hoot that I would have
barked in during a biker bar
in Santa Barbara County.
I lived there for 10 years, ghost writers.
It's I can say that
because it's been sold
and the copy rights are
- So you've had jobs.
You've had
- Worked at Cedar Sinai
hospital for seven years.
And I worked at King hospital
in the ER for two years.
And from 1988 to 1990
when LA was the gunshot
capital of the world.
And in 19, from 1988 to 1990, the military
there's a landing base
on top of the hospital.
They used to bring their medics
and to train them for gunshot.
Because if you get shot, you want to
you go to Connie LSE or King,
cause they have more gunshots.
They build, they're more
likely to save you better
than Cedar Sinai when
it comes to gun wounds.
because the, where, where it is.
I mean, when I was growing up
before I started working that
I started working very young.
I was a go getter.
I was highly motivated.
And when I first got the
job at King in the ER
it's just every day, gunshot
wounds, young boys, young boys.
And they generally stabilized him.
And it it's changed now
because they all killed
each other and went to jail.
That's how it ended.
I saw it, before I was 18
I went to over 30
funerals, over 30 funeral.
My brother I experienced myself
was murdered at the age of 15.
His name was Maurice Deshaun, 1984
October the 14th on
there, forget that day.
And it was gang violence, but up
and down Crenshaw Boulevard,
every day someone was murdered
and it was never talked about in paper,
And that's when mayor
Tom Bradley was here.
my family is a church family.
So we're kind of bout about not kind of
we are about the community.
And so we do go to community counseling.
I have a couple of family
members on the council wards
and just being part of the community
but what Julie changed, LA
everyone who's here now.
They're not from here.
And, and, and if you don't know me
you not from here, cause I've been here.
Like, yeah, I remember
when there was no tense.
I remember when I remember
when there was no Crips
my mother and father were black Panthers.
And I learned that as I got older
because my father would
take me to the meaner.
I was a little girl.
I said, serve cookies.
I don't know what the hell is going on.
There's just people talking.
I didn't know what the blood
department, I did not know that
until my father, he was like,
baby girl, don't you remember?
I'm like, dad, you took
me to black part for me.
Like it was family.
- So the, the, the recent
black lives matter things
that have been going on in our country.
How do you, how do you see that?
Is, does your albinism affect your
- Oh, my perspective of it?
Yeah, of course.
I really feel that they know
from an Obama perspective,
and this is for society sake
people to put too much
emphasis on skin color, no one
especially black people,
especially my people.
I mean, within the sub culture.
And I've been affected
by gang violence, within
within my culture and
black lives does matter
but black people have to
embody that themselves first
if they want other
subcultures to recognize
that it has to be grass root,
it has to be grassroots.
And it has to be practiced religiously.
And it's not just about, one
some attention and being
political, because this has gone
on before we burned the whole city
down because of one black life
and the whole city burned
because of one black life.
So we embodied that here
in LA, we totally do.
But then after we burn the city down
everybody get tired,
And then they just go back
to the same behavior, which manifest this.
What's going on now to begin with,
to what could the aided it
it's the behavior within the subculture.
if you want black lives to matter
you have to convey that every day
as a black person and
it's silent, it's silent
you don't have to bark it out
just walk it, practice it, do it.
And you can say a lot
by just doing it and
not just screaming out.
And it's so many, my son went
to Canoga park high and it was in 2000
there was a private war between
the Hispanic and the black.
They were gunning people
down this right outside
of Chatsworth, 2000, 2002.
They never put it in a newspaper
because it wasn't nothing
but Mexicans killing blacks.
And they wanted those houses to sell,
Ralph Roscoe, Parthenia
where all the apartments are
they were slaughtering each other, walking
down the street and that's,
and, and it was a silent war
and it was in a Valley, but,
and a lot of the black parents
a lot of the black people
who lost their children
walking home, didn't say anything.
if, if black lives matter
make the matter, as a black person,
I moved out to protect to say
I have a 31 year old son
who happens to people at
I left canonical park and moved
to Santa Barbara to save his life.
Cause there's was carnage.
And all these,
black people who are expressing
this need to be noticed
and recognized and respected
have to start doing it within the culture.
They have to do it.
And if they want other
people to do it well, no
one's going to do it for you.
And I truly feel deeply about
this because I lost her.
I was 14 when my brother died.
And when I went to his
funeral is closed Catholic
because they shot him in the
face with a sawed-off shotgun
a 15 year old little boy,
they shot his leg off.
And then they shot him
in the face up close.
And, and this, when LA was a
war zone, it was like Beirut.
I have to run home every day
getting shot at just to get an
education, just to graduate.
And in order to go to the
Valley, I was busted the Valley.
Cause I got good grades,
but, the same thing
the that's in you growing
up with they in the hood
you could be, they riding
the bus with you, right.
For real.
So it's fighting on the
school, but before you get
to the VAT like that, and,
but LA has cleaned up a lot.
me seeing it, it's a lot
it's becoming more diverse again
because all the game bangers
and they all killed each other
Dan and they dead pretty much.
And it's just and crack, okay.
And not the drug of choice anymore.
It's meth.
And that's a whole different
beast way different,
And, and it changed the climate.
It changed the Plains of
LA it's way different.
That's way more quiet people more.
But having this condition
here, one thing this happened
to me, I left cause I moved,
I moved to Santa Barbara.
I stayed there for 10
years, but I will come back
and visit the house I grew up and was born
in and I'm walking down the
street, going to see my father
and the police swooped
up next to me and said
what in the hell do you think you're going
what are you doing here?
I'm like, I live here.
What are you doing here?
- And how you not from here?
Thought you were white.
- Right. And suto for me and the hell.
Do you think you're dumb?
Like what the hell do
you think you are doing?
See that house right there
with all them black pivotal plays.
The one that you always run
up with you that's my house.
I was born there.
They're like, Oh
- Proceed.
- Because they, they were new.
They were rookies.
what I mean?
- Have you seen other
racist and like reactions
people that thought you were, Oh yeah.
- Yeah, definitely.
Why agent?
Most people except black
people, they know I'm black, but
outside myself culture, they,
they think I'm Norwegian.
Anything but black,
anything popular, they find
out you're black outs.
I have to demand it.
I'm not check this out.
Then I show them and they're
like, Oh, I believe you.
But it's, it's, it's, it's funny.
It's entertaining makes me laughter.
How people respond to me, how
they behave, how they stare
- So route.
- But I I've managed to have fun with it
make money off of it.
they hire me just to be me.
I don't have to do nothing, but be myself.
And if don't like what they see
they can turn their head
and look the other way.
Right?
- Yeah. It's interesting how you've
turned something that could be something
that keeps you down into something that
- Money. I got it all.
Every job, even getting that
job at Cedars-Sinai hospital.
I was a hospital.
I was the coordinator
there of the communication
between the doctors and the
nurses and all the girls.
They had, they had an
exotic look of 23, 22, 22.
And I started working there
and, and we were all friends.
We all secretary, but each
one of us had an exotic what?
And that's what they is Hollywood.
And I know that's how I got that job.
I know.
That's how that's.
I know that's why they hired me.
Not only could I was able to type
and do the job, but also it was hard.
- You're fun to look at.
So what your interesting perspective
on being African-American what insights
can you share that way?
- All plea from a main race,
other way, mankind said
there's only one race, the
human race, the word race
as a separate of the
ethnicity is a construct.
We all of us bleed from
it into the same cup
and I'm living proof of that.
And, and that's the only
thing that I've learned.
And no one told me this
this is something that
I came to understand
just being this way
dealing with society, and I've traveled.
I've been in London, I've
been to Jamaica and Canada
and stepping outside and, and it's
and people like me, even
outside of the United
the state boundary,
there's very superstitious
about people like me,
Jamaica, full, forget it.
they got, I'm a, what you want, man.
and I am, no, I am, but, but the society
and the superstitions
and what people believe,
and if, and this it's called a construct
if a lot of people said
enough, it becomes true.
- W what I see after
talking to so many people is
if you believe you're a victim right.
It would be very easy for somebody who is
- Living to victimize.
- Well, I mean, if you
think generationally
if somebody is living in poverty
and they're African-American, and
they're a victim, right.
But if they chose to not be
a victim and do kind acts
for other people of all colors and races
and wealth backgrounds and
everything, and just be a kind
of person that everyone goes, wow, I met
that dude yesterday, and can't
stop thinking about them.
Right. And if that kept
happening generation
after generation, then there
would be no victimization
of anyone.
It would just be like, Oh my
God, these people are great.
I met three of them last
week, and one was nicer
than the next
but that doesn't seem to
be happening right now
- And see, that's my point.
- Well, I mean, there's lots of
there's lots of demands
to treat me better.
I understand that
- You have to manifest it.
You have to practice it.
You, you have to do it,
And then if you convey it and it into
as convenience as a
practice, you're doing it.
You don't have to say
nothing, it's you convey it.
And you just don't walk in
a room and demand, respect.
You can't do that.
Especially not down here, not down here.
And, and, believe it or not on skid row.
It's a huge melting
pot here for the silent
especially with the Asians.
We've been like this for years.
what I mean?
The Asians
and the black down here,
the Hispanic, the Mexicans
and the El Salvador, they
run MacArthur park, black.
There's always been
back territory, always.
And a lot in what keeps
me alive down here.
Half of these are related to me.
They got baby by people in
my family, married my family.
what I mean?
They know me.
And that's why I'm going to with me
because they know me
and the people who don't
know me don't know who watching them.
And, could have been
there by no down here.
That's the only thing keeps
me shaved half the most
the other day to me, because trust me
if I came down here by
myself and didn't know nobody
it would have been a slaughter.
look, they're all predators.
They living in tents
because they off the radar.
They running from the feds, whoever right
- Around the corner from everybody
- And themselves and themselves.
- But what's the most
important lesson you've learned
to write.
- No, one's above it.
No one's greater or lesser.
We're all the same.
And Julie, and it's not the
color of a person's scan it.
Dr. Kane says the creed,
it's their character and their
practice and their behavior.
And as a black person and a white person,
because black people in
white people stay shepherded.
So they really know each other.
We're just getting in LA is different.
We've been together out here,
but people from other places
bringing that separatism
here, we never had that here.
When I grew up in South central,
my family were homeowners.
It was Asian people on the house.
Next door we used to play together.
it was white people.
It wasn't in the eighties
and seventies in LA.
It was a melting pot.
And even why, so hook Carson
white people still live
there on the houses.
They probably rent them out now
but there's still the original owners.
And we all grew up together.
It was just, I mean, even the jungle now
why people starting to come back?
The Jews there, wasn't
given up the property.
They still own it.
They were just leasing it.
And now I knew that I grew up
over there, right over there.
And Midtown Pico
Redondo Houser caught,
Hancock park, toilet place
up. No, I told her that.
And that's how I got to say about that.
- But what's your favorite
personality trait that you have?
You have a lot of them
- When I'm nervous.
I like to tell jokes.
It breaks your eyes.
It makes people laugh.
And it gives you time to
think of something else.
If that's where you're trying to escape
you crack a joke on, they laugh at
you creep up to the door to get out.
- And what do you think
would help our society?
Most, this is a rough
time for a lot of people.
What do you think?
What do you think we should
pay more attention to?
- People should pay more attention
to themselves and make
themselves a better person.
If you were working on yourself
you wouldn't have time to look
and criticized someone else.
You wouldn't be paying
attention to them because
you will be too busy doing what
you're supposed to be doing.
And if each individual did their job
we will run like Canada.
And it will be a well-functioning society
after generation at the gym.
It'll manifest, but every role model
for your kids and your kids.
Yeah.
But it has to do that's the
type of family I came from.
I mean, we had killers,
scholars Hillers and killers.
I had school teacher
doctor in my family, but
I got to do both sides of the spectrum.
And it was because of my
albinism that I was accepted.
I've been places that my sisters
and brothers can't come in.
Cause the color of their skin,
they won't invite you in.
You have to be able to blend
in with the family photos,
especially when you're outside
you're outside yourself, cup them.
When you're in a white
society, it's easier to get in.
If you look like them, it's no question.
They don't question it.
But, but if most people as
individual pay more attention
to themselves and, and contribute, empty
self-motivated get off your
and do something right.
Quick bark, and then complain
about what you're not getting.
If you're not getting up and
trying to get it yourself
it's not going to be handed to you.
And that's all I can say about that.
- Excellent. Thank you so
much for talking with me.
You're fabulous.
- Oh, you just said
that because it's true.
(laughing)